what's good everybody welcome welcome
welcome into another edition of Market
takes a very special edition of Market
takes we are of course breaking down the
consumer price index report that just
came out at 8 30 this morning but of
course you know Market takes isn't just
about looking at the data market takes
is about analyzing the data and we can't
do that without talking about what's
going on with Silicon Valley Bank some
of these Bank runs that we're seeing out
here and and just we're going to dive
all the way into what's happening with
the overall economy so we're going to
talk through all of that right here on
Market takes I'm your host Dion rabone
reporter for the Wall Street Journal we
are going to dive all the way into it
look we're going to talk about what the
CPI report said we're going to assess
the state of the economy and the markets
like I said talk a little bit about
these Bank issues that were heat that
we're seeing we're going to check in on
the markets as well because we know
markets tell us a lot about what's going
on and how investors perceive that and
what can happen next and of course we're
going to explain what today's report
tells is about the future because we are
always looking forward even though it's
backwards looking data and we're going
to talk about the big picture what comes
next so listen without any further Ado
let's dive all the way into the CPI
report the report showed that in
February inflation Rose at a six percent
year-over-year Pace uh the core
inflation Rose at 5.5 percent and month
over month was about point four percent
so you see this chart that's up there on
your screen now I wanted to put this up
here to just show the overall pace of
inflation the way that it's risen and
the way that it's come back down in
recent months so you see that Peak up
there the highest bar you see that's in
June that's what inflation CPI inflation
Rose to nine percent we have come back
down to about six percent what does that
tell you well as Charles Schwab Chief
fix Chief fixed income strategist Kathy
Kathy Jones tells US inflation is quote
trending lower but still high that six
percent still way above what we were at
even in the early days of 2020 before
the covet pandemic and we are still very
high the FED wants to get us down to two
percent that's close to some of those
levels you see on the other side of your
screen as you can see we are very far
from that so just wanted to put that up
there to kind of illustrate where we've
been where we've come from where we are
and kind of why the market is expecting
what it's expecting for the future
now this report came in a little bit
below expectations the expectation among
economists surveyed by Dow Jones or for
6.1 percent year-over-year inflation and
point five percent month over month so
we were just a tad below that but
inflation overall coming in doing what
it was expected to do but we know it's
not just about what the headline number
is right we're conscientious Market
Watchers we know it's not just about the
headline numbers that's going to move
those plebes over there who aren't
really watching the market we know it's
all about context so we're going to dive
into what a little bit of that context
means real quick thing I want to point
out from a line from the bls's CPI
report quote the index for shelter was
the largest contributors the monthly all
items increased accounting for over 70
percent of the increase it was also 60
percent of the core increase core is
when you strip out volatile food and
energy prices uh from the reading so
shelter AKA housing AKA what you're
paying for rent what you're paying for
your mortgage all those things that that
was accounting for 70 percent of the
overall increase in CPI now why does
that matter well not only does it mean
that that prices for rent and housing
and shelter are increasing which we've
known for a while but
the FED Fed chair Jerome Palace come out
and said look our our real-time
indicators are showing us that rent
prices are going down that shelter
prices are going down that overall
people are paying less money for where
they live so if the shelter index is
taking up 70 or accounts for 70 of the
increase well that tells you that maybe
inflation actually isn't that freaking
work we know this is a lagging indicator
we know it takes a while for the actual
price of housing to get factored into
the report even when housing is starting
to move in an opposite direction it can
take a while for that to get factored in
the Bureau of Labor Statistics that told
us that has told me that personally and
they really don't have a good
explanation for why or how long it takes
or a way to really account for that so
we know that there is this delayed
metric that is keeping inflation higher
than it otherwise would be you're
keeping CPI inflation higher than it
otherwise would be that's good news for
investors who are looking for maybe the
FED to pump the brakes a little bit to
stop its hiking cycle so we know these
things and we've seen that we've seen
this report that suggests that maybe
okay even though inflation according to
CPI is still six percent it could
actually be lower than that also a
little bit of good news want to make
sure I don't miss this
um in contrast to the overall food index
the meats poultry fish and eggs index
fell point one percent over the month I
know y'all been going crazy about eggs
egg prices actually fell down the index
for eggs fell 6.7 in February following
sharp increases in recent months
according to BLS that's some good news
so maybe we can go out and get eggs
again soon get them omelettes going
um I know it's been a while for me since
I had um but those egg prices have been
crazy
um
I want to get into the other piece of
bad news though for this report and
again we got to dive into the context
the core Services X shelter AKA super
core and remember Fed chair drone Palace
said super core is what they're watching
that was up
0.427 AKA point four percent or point
four three percent versus point two six
five percent last month what does that
mean the index that the Federal Reserve
has honed in on that fed share Jerome
Powell said hey this is the most
important thing we're watching that Rose
and Rose by a lot more than it did the
previous month so what we're seeing is
Services things like going to your
lawyer things like buying a trip a plane
ticket
um going to see your chiropractor all
those things are rising in price and
they're rising at a pretty significant
pace and picking up pace not slowing
down so that's why we have seen I think
a lot of the reaction we've seen from
the bond market we'll get into that in
just a little bit
um I talked about this we did a big
report uh wsj.com about what is super
core inflation if you're not familiar
familiar make sure you check that out
we're going to link to it in the in the
comments or in the video description so
be sure and check that out
that increased a lot more we saw that in
Recreation that it was up 0.9 household
furnishings and operations at point
eight percent airline fares up 6.4
percent year over year ending a string
of four consecutive declines that's big
um also index for Motor Vehicle
Insurance increase so this puts the FED
in a little bit of a bind because
they've been saying super core super
core super core but they also might want
to pause here they also want to say hey
we've got this banking Fiasco going on
well maybe we need to pause what we're
doing that's what a lot of folks out
there are saying Barclays Goldman Sachs
among the big names saying the fed's
going to pause at its monthly meeting
not hike 50 basis points as had
previously been expected but hike zero
basis points not move this month let
things settle down it's going to be
harder for them to do that when you've
got the super core inflation the measure
that they have spotlighted and said this
is what we're watching that's increasing
and increasing at a faster Pace than it
was last month so let's take another
step back here pause pause all this talk
about CPI because inflation isn't
important to the overall Narrative of
course it also plays a big role in this
Bank narrative that we're seeing right
these Bank runs the collapse and the
failure of Silicon Valley Bank of
Signature Bank the second and third
largest bank failures in the history of
the United States one quick thing I want
to throw up here to illustrate what
we're talking about in terms of trouble
in the banking sector this is the KBW
Bank
ETF it's the NASDAQ Bank index basically
all the biggest banks in the U.S are in
this uh this ETF if you don't know what
an ETF is it's just a collection of a
bunch of different stock prices put
together that make one stock index or
one exchange traded fund this is
Citigroup JPMorgan Wells PNC Bank of
America Huntington Beach Comerica all
really the biggest banks out there and
you can see just falling off the cliff
they're down about 20 percent in just
the last few days this index is down
about 15 percent year-to-date it's down
18 in the past five days that is a huge
decline and you're seeing some of these
troubles in the banking sector so just
wanted to throw up there that chart to
illustrate that this is not just one
bank this is across the board the
banking sector is in trouble there's
some worries about contagion I'm going
to talk about why some of those may be
founded and why they may be a little bit
unfounded so let's first talk about
Silicon Valley Bank biggest bank failure
since the global financial crisis 209
billion dollars in total assets 175
billion in deposits as of December 22.
as of December 2022
um the country's 16th largest overall
Bank the Federal Reserve stepped in
declared it systemically important and
was able to create a new fund to make
sure all those depositors were made
whole uh as well as Signature Bank that
would have been the next largest or the
third largest or that was the third
largest uh bank failure in the history
of the U.S so I want to break down why
that happened and why that could have
effects on the overall banking sector
the overall economy and why it may not
why it's something you might need to
worry about why it's something you might
not so let's simplify let's say instead
of 200 billion 202 billion 209 billion
excuse me instead of 209 billion in
deposits let's say Silicon Valley had
100 billion dollars in deposits let's
say they had 10 depositors again just to
keep this simple this is these are not
the real numbers we're going to simplify
this now if this Bank Silicon Valley had
a hundred billion dollars in deposits
they're not keeping 100 billion dollars
in a safe somewhere at the bank no no no
they're investing a lot of this money
they're using that to make loans they're
only keeping around let's call it 10
billion dollars for simplicity's sake
the Federal Reserve actually lowered
bank's reserve requirement ratio to zero
in March 2020 it has not raised it back
up since so technically they could just
be keeping about 35 40 million dollars
if they wanted to but for the sake of
this example let's say they're keeping
10 billion dollars let's say they only
have 10 clients right so each client has
10 billion dollars well
banks are investing this money for
Silicon Valley Bank it was a lot of
treasuries a lot of mortgage-backed
Securities a lot of stuff that that is
pretty safe a lot of things that you
know folks in the banking sector the
Federal Reserve says you should invest
in this not into meme stocks and things
like that
um Banks invest in a lot of different
things part of this is mortgages as well
that was a big part of Silicon Valley
Banks all of those things are losing
value bonds losing value stocks losing
value mortgage is losing value commodity
is losing value if you put money in
something a year ago in March 2022 it is
likely to be worth less now and so the
problem is that these Banks had this
money in deposits they took it out of
the deposits they invested it and now
that money is worth less than the amount
of deposits they have so they had a
hundred billion dollars in assets let's
say for simplicity's sake they had a
diversified portfolio that is now down
20 well now they only have 80 billion
dollars and they have a hundred billion
dollars worth of liabilities as in what
they have to pay if everyone in the bank
came to demand their money so what's
been happening recently Silicon Valley
was very reliant on the Venture Capital
industry venture capital A lot of
startups a lot of tech that's been hit
very hard and you've seen folks kind of
fleeing the space you're seeing a lot of
these companies burning through cash
which means they're not bringing money
in but they still got to pay they got to
pay for a headcount they got to pay
suppliers they got to pay to keep the
lights on they got to pay for their rent
so that money has just been getting
pulled out by deposits a lot faster than
money has been going in
at the same time a lot of these
companies you've got the the
unemployment rate really staying low but
a lot of folks being laid off these Tech
layoffs that you've heard folks are
scared they're worried so again they're
pulling out cash they're they're having
to spend that as that same thing is
happening you are seeing that Silicon
Valley Bank's Investments are declining
so they've only got this let's say 80
billion dollars and now let's say one
client says hey you know what listen
um I need a I need my 10 billion dollars
back things aren't looking so good I'm
having to pay a lot of money over here
I'm just gonna need my 10 billion
dollars back in cash Silicon Valley they
don't want to do it but they have to do
it because they owe that money that's
the client's money they have to give it
to them so now all of a sudden Silicon
Valley has zero dollars in cash and
they've got 80 billion dollars invested
that should be a hundred billion dollars
well now they've got to figure out okay
we've got to either sell some of these
things that we've got at a loss take the
loss on our books and and you know have
less money overall and one of the things
that Silicon Valley Bank did is they put
this in a special category called holds
matured which means they didn't have to
mark down the losses they were taking on
because they plan to hold the bonds
until they matured as in when when you
have a bond you buy it you say you
basically give a loan to whoever is
whoever is selling the bond you say okay
I will buy your bonds U.S government in
the case of treasuries and then you get
all that money back plus some interest
but the the problem is a lot of silicon
Valley's assets were held at a rate at a
duration of 10 years so Silicon Valley
is borrowing they expect to get paid
back in 10 years or more and they're
saying we're going to hold this thing so
we don't even need to mark down the
losses because we're never going to take
any losses because this thing will be
worth exactly what we paid for it and
we're gonna make money in 10 years well
if you got to sell it before 10 years
because you've got to get money you've
got to get cash to your clients you've
got to get money back so you have some
available that means you got to sell the
loss what they did instead was they
tried to sell stock to raise money to
meet some of these some of these cash
flow issues and Moody's investor service
the ratings agency caught wind of this
they said oh no no no we see your losses
we see your cash position we see that a
lot of people are pulling money out of
your bank we are going to downgrade you
well when that downgrade came there were
some folks watching out anyway they said
hold on wait a second VC industry in
trouble Tech in trouble uh markets in
trouble their investments in trouble we
should pull our money out so now more
people are pulling money out of the bank
and so instead of that first client who
pulled his 10 million dollars out of her
10 million set 10 billion dollars out
excuse me now another client comes and
says hey oh I've heard about this my
financial advisor says I need to get my
10 billion dollars out now another
client says I need to get my 10 billion
dollars out well now you've lost three
clients you've had to pay 30 billion
dollars out your your portfolio is down
about 20 percent so you've got less
money available and now you're gonna
have to sell more things well you don't
have that money you don't have the money
to meet all the liabilities or all the
clients that you have you don't have
their money anymore their money has lost
value you try to do the stock sale you
couldn't you wanted to do another one
but you can't because the Market's going
to punish you your stock price is
plummeting so you can't even issue more
stock and that's how we end up in a bank
run with a failure of the second largest
bank or the second largest bank failure
in U.S history that's why we got there
now here's why that's worrisome first of
all lots of banks behave this way you've
got lots of banks this is typical Bank
behavior taking deposits from customers
and using them to buy assets and
securities that has been typical Bank
behavior for quite some time the
glass-style ACT remember that was done
away within deregulation oh we don't
want regulation that's bad get rid of
Glass Tiger which keeps Bank from
investing deposits okay now they can
invest deposits they can make loans on
those remember housing prices are going
down we're seeing mortgage values to
clients so basically anywhere you'd put
your money you're seeing lower valuation
for that
um and this low Reserve ratio
requirement for banks means that they
don't need to keep a lot of money around
and in fact a lot of them have been
keeping a very close to minimum levels
of cash on the books The Reserve ratio
requirement is zero the reserve
requirement ratio is zero they only have
to keep I think it's 36 million dollars
on hand and they want to use that other
money to make money they want to invest
the same way if someone gave you some
money you'd say hey I can invest this in
treasuries get four or five percent I
can invest in stocks and earn some money
on that money because you're basically
getting it for free and now you can go
make some money with it so that's why
we're seeing this as worrisome because
other folks are looking at some of these
other Banks especially these Regional
Banks uh things like First Republic
we've seen their stock get hit really
hard also Zions Bank Pacific West
Western Alliance all these other banks
that are sort of mid-tier regional banks
that have a lot of deposits that are
higher than 250 000 and that have
invested a lot and have and have lost
seen losses on their portfolio folks
think the big guys are pretty safe
because they've got a ton of cash
deposits about half of all the money
deposited at FDIC insured Banks is at
five banks the big five uh JPMorgan City
U.S Bank uh Wells Fargo I'm forgetting
one but forgive me
the great news about too big to fail
institutions is that they have a lot of
cash they're very safe the bad news is a
lot of these other banks that are not
too big to fail they have a lot less
cash so let's also talk about why this
isn't worrisome and that gets to why we
may not see a bank run throughout the
whole system first of all the Federal
Reserve has stepped in set up a new
facility with 25 billion dollars of
capital they say the discount window is
still open Banks if you need cash we got
you uh they've come out and really kind
of solidified that and said we're going
to be doing more here the FED also
flooded the system with money look the
Federal Reserve can create money out of
thin air they pump it into the economy
they can get it to these Banks banking
sector has a lot more regulations in
terms of how much Capital they need to
hold but a lot of what they have to hold
instead of cash is these treasury bonds
that have been losing value again a big
bank can take on those treasuries and
there's not really a big risk for them
when they take that on because they know
we've got enough cash to pay out these
depositors we're all good so the big
Banks not doing so well this is great
news for Bank safety it's not such great
news for Consumer choice and that's why
there's a lot of worry about what this
could mean but that's also why when it
comes to a systemic failure of the
banking system where issues with the
overall banking system well people
aren't quite as worried let's really
quick check in with markets right now
just want to talk through what we're
seeing across the board in markets
stocks are up big we're seeing a really
big reaction to the CPI report or maybe
just to it not being yesterday or it not
being Friday with all these bank
failures you've seen the NASDAQ about
1.8 percent the s p up about 1.6 percent
I think that's very interesting in the
way it contrasts what we're seeing in
the bond market we are seeing yields up
big time at the short end of the curve
now when I'm talking about the one-year
treasury bill is up 38 basis points
right now the two year is up about 36
basis points now what does that mean
those are expectations for Fed rate
hikes that means the market sees the FED
doing more after this CPI report and I
think that goes back to that super core
number that we talked about up about
point four three percent after being
about 0.26 last month uh investors in
the bond market are much more closely
watching the economy much more closely
watching developments like this super
core and like this CPI report then stock
investors are and I think that's why
you're seeing this Divergence now both
treasure yields are up which means bond
prices are down and stock prices are up
in a big way right now and I think that
has a lot to do with the way the market
is interpreting this CPI report when we
talk through and we look at currencies
we're seeing the dollar a little bit
higher about 0.2 percent again that
means when you've seen those yields rise
you're seeing the dollar but you're not
seeing a big move in those 10-year
30-year yields those have been very
little very very little moved by the
support euro is up about point one
percent dollar is up big against the
Japanese Yen definitely keep your eye on
that we look out at those Commodities
oil down about one percent it's making a
recovery a gold down about point three
percent natural gas and about 2.25
percent natural gas has been a big loser
for a while call your Energy company and
ask them why they're charging you more
for your bills while natural gas is at
the lowest price it's been in about 15
20 years take that for me as Market
takes news you can use
um we're going to talk through a little
bit about how this relates back to
overall inflation listen what inflation
means is that when inflation is high the
FED raises rates to try and cool it down
if we see inflation hold up that's what
causes those things like treasury bills
to rise like mortgage rates to rise and
that has been hitting the value of these
mortgage bonds so a lot of these issues
are related directly to what we're
seeing in the banking industry banks are
investors they invest the money and when
the markets are losing because the
Federal Reserve is raising rates that
creates an issue for a lot of these
Banks and if you see inflation persist
you could see a lot of these issues for
the banks persist I want to take one
more look at inflation and just kind of
contextualize and illustrate what we're
seeing overall with CPI and what we have
seen for a while so you look back there
at January 2020 what did we see so when
inflation really you know January or
sorry March 2020 is when the covid
pandemic first hit the U.S you saw CPI
inflation dive and then you see it kind
of start to pick up noticeably and then
really just ratchet what happened we got
the karazak three trillion dollars of
stimulus you got the Trump stimulus uh
the Trump lame duck stimulus at the end
of 2020 you got the American Rescue
package from President Joe Biden and
that's where you start to see those
inflation numbers really pick up but
don't forget March 2020 was when the FED
started QE Infinity that's when they
said we are going to buy as many bonds
as necessary we're going to do whatever
it takes and you really see the monetary
the money supply just explode and you
saw so businesses have lots of money
from the FED you've got low borrowing
rates they loaded up on a lot of debt
now the money is starting to run out now
investors are betting that this
inflation is going to go away by the end
of of the Year 2023 but as you can see
up there on your screen we are still at
six percent so just wanted to throw that
up there to illustrate the kind of trend
for inflation that we've seen we also I
just put a video out yesterday on the
page check it out it's about what's
happening with delinquencies and we've
seen this huge build up and pick up and
credit and people taking on more credit
card debt and more debt overall and now
we're starting to see delinquencies pick
up definitely check that out if you
haven't
um Hey listen that's going to really
wrap it up for us here on Market takes
this report really tells us that
inflation is still an issue it's a
bigger issue and that the FED is going
to have some choices to make do they
focus on price stability or do they
focus on financial stability and that's
going to be the big question when they
meet March 21st and March 22nd we will
be right here on March 22nd that's next
Wednesday talking through the FED
decision the outcome the statement all
that good stuff and what fed share
Jerome Palace to say but before that
tomorrow is going to be another exciting
day on the market retail sales is out
we'll be breaking it down right here on
Market Day thanks I hope you'll be there
don't be a
that's going to do it for us here on
Market takes thanks so much for joining
us I'm Dion rabone with photo with the
Wall Street Journal we'll see you next
time